hey what's up guys my name is a chana
and welcome to episode 87 of game
programming so last time we took a look
at actually making these um these sub
sprite shades as I called them I don't
think there's actually an official term
for that so I just you know sub sprite
shape whatever someone asked seed and
don't I don't know I kind of made that
up that's not an official term I don't
know I don't I don't actually know what
they called officially but what we've
got here is a way to create sprite
shades from spreadsheets so in other
words we can grab an image file and from
that we can extract individual sprite
shapes in this case strips to the player
of course because if we take a look at
our player again in our game directory
here you can see that it's actually
divided into more or less for different
sprite sheets one each for each
direction that he can actually walk in
so because of that now we could of
course make diagonal directions as well
if we really wanted to but because of
that we've had to kind of make help this
this method here so now that we've got a
way to actually extract extract these
sheets why not make a way to actually
manage animated sprites properly now
there are a few reasons why we wouldn't
do that okay
um we're gonna essentially do it now but
we're not gonna automate the entire
process and the reason is that of course
animations require updates the way that
we animate things in our in our game
right now is that we we basically
iterate through the the frames as time
goes on right it's an array and we kind
of flip through all of the sprites in
that array as time goes on time in the
game that is updates go on now if we
were to make a animated sprite we would
of course have to have an update method
in here and the thing is how would we
then update that sprite that's kind of
flawed it's not it's not absolutely
flawed but the thing is if you look I'm
over here until I level the thing that
dictates updates here is of course these
lists and adding a creating one for
sprites would just be impractical so
we're going to kind of work around that
and and makes
that is actually quite practical and
quite um quite powerful so here in
graphics I'm gonna make a new class here
called sprite
I'm sorry animated sprite okay and it's
actually going to extend sprite so you
could go ahead and select it here like
that but I'm not going to because um I
could actually but essentially it'll you
know you just have to type in just have
to type out extend sprite okay so in
other words make sure that animator
sprite extends right okay so okay so
it's not learning us automatically okay
there they are so we have to obviously
use one of the constructors that we
provided in sprite let's take a look
over here we have a bunch of different
constructors here I think one that I'll
probably want to use is an atom an
animated sprite is essentially going to
instead of taking and I made it an
animated sprite is going to consist of
multiple sprites right and these
multiple sprites it should just be able
to get them from a spreadsheet so to
make an animated sprite all you really
should need is a sprite sheet okay
and then of course we deal with this
error because if it's a sprite and then
it has to get all these traits so let's
just go ahead and look over here should
it be a sprite I'm looking okay so this
has a sprite shade this has a pixel all
right yeah okay this is pretty much a
sprite so what I want to do over here is
I'm going to okay so in size in accident
Y as well as the sprite sheet we have
int okay so we don't have one that fits
perfectly so let's grab a um and let's
make another all right here in sprite
this will be a we won't have in accident
Y but rather what we'll have is a silent
a sprite shade
okay now you could argue that this is
kind of impractical because um well the
thing is we're not really gonna use this
for sprites are way it will be kind of
it's the only way the only reason would
use this is for sprite so because of
that
I'm probably gonna do is just thinking
now let's keep it like that yeah let's
keep it like that let's make it
protected there I was gonna just make a
default constructor here but not gonna
do that
so um the only way to do this is well
technically all these guys should be
pretty much prior to protected because
we're all right initializing them here
but what's gonna make sure that this one
is protected since it should only be
used by my sprite because there's
absolutely no reason you do this
otherwise so let's say let's set size
equal to size and let's share let's set
um this Dutch sheets equal to shape okay
and that's all we're going to do oh we
should also of course set this dot width
equal to width and they still hire
people to hire okay cool
oh sorry to sheet oh no sorry sighs we
want to set that equal to size again
this kind of assumes non um non square
surprised I'm not sure if I'm after that
there's so many ways we could do this
let's um let's make let's just make in
with him in height for now it's also
sizable down negative one and we'll do
what we did last time which is um we
said last time that if whoops let me
spell height properly well we said last
time that if if width equals high then
let's set size equal to a width else
we'll set size equal to negative one
there's actually a better way to do this
we could just simply say size equals
width equals heights if true size equals
with else size equals negative one so
you could do it this way of course and I
would just condense it into one
statement here
that didn't walk
oh sorry my bad yes we could do it this
way and let's get rid of this so it's
been a while since I've used this method
here but essentially what this does is
just condenses those two lines into one
so it basically what it does is it sets
size to a conditional property here so
in other words what it does is it says
that if with if this property is true
let's set size equal to this else set it
equal to that so that's how I work okay
it's really simple just a quick trick
that a few of you might not have been
aware of so once we've done that let's
go back to animate a sprite and let's
actually just add int with an int height
through the constructor here so that we
um okay I think I'm pretty sure that's
the same constructor we defined is it
yes it is okay great so let's make sure
that we um do of course super it and
okay Brian so what we can do now is add
a few things that are only are only
appropriate for animated sprites such as
you know frame for example okay another
one that we could add is well I'm
thinking now that's probably about it
so what's that frame equal to zero to
start off with other things that we
might want to define is of course an
update method as I mentioned earlier
another thing we might want to define
here is a we want we want to define a
get sprite method and this will return
our sprite here sprite might be
something that some subjective to this
class as well because of course a sprite
is a sprite um and let's see what else
we need I'm just thinking well we may
want to get we might want to set the
frame rate of course so set set frame
rate
and this isn't really gonna be strictly
a frame it's not gonna be really a frame
rater than frames per second but it's
going to be a rate at which we can
control the things so I'll call it
private int rate equals we'll set it
equals like five for default so they
start or just write equals friends okay
cool so now that we've done this we
should do basically the same thing that
we didn't player which is we basically
just said that um if we were to advance
this we basically said that if oh we
need to find a size as well that's very
important let's do that now actually
it's so private and I'll just call this
some animation sighs okay it calls a
zero to begin with because this is
incredibly important so what we need to
do is somehow get the the amount of
frames in this thing I'm thinking okay
yeah that's fine what we'll have to
actually make another one here the more
I'm making this some more I'm thinking
that I might ascribe really doesn't have
much to do with the sprite apart from
width and height so um I know what you
guys are probably thinking especially
those of you a bit more advanced
probably thinking you know does an
animated sprite really have to extend
the sprite because it's just so much
different but I'm probably gonna leave
it at that for now because um and the
reason for that is because I want people
to be able to set any sprite equal to be
an animated sprite mm-hmm and that of
course works through inheritance it more
or less more it kind of more implements
or sprite and extends it to be honest
because well overriding like all the
methods but anyway so hmm we need
animation size and we're gonna specify
that here so animation size and this is
more of an animation length I might want
on my call it if that I'm just gonna
call it length okay so the length is the
amount of frames that we have in our
animation here so I'll set length equal
to 0 to begin with in fact negative 1
because 0 is an invalid value so as
innocent valid and we can't possibly
have an animated sprite with 0 frames
and because otherwise it's just
non-existent so we want to make sure we
throw an error if that happens ok cool
so let's um make
that we set length equal to length
softballs this dot length equals rank
and over here we want to say that if
frames is actually greater than length
yeah we want to obviously reset frames
back to zero because otherwise um it's
from are in fact just to be smarter oh
let's see
no I could just do price because it
doesn't matter which way you do this you
could do it the other way around so in
other words if frames is less and length
frames plus plus else frames equals zero
but doesn't matter if write frames I
really made frame okay cool so what
that's gonna do is advance a frames and
what we need to do now is find a way to
actually get a specific sprite in a
sprite sheet okay because the idea here
is that we want to set sprite equal to
an appropriate sprite here so out of the
sheet I don't think we've got to get
sprite method from here don't we
okay let's make one so public void get
sprite and what's very public sprite
gets bright and what this will do is
extract a single sprite out of our um
out of our out of our sprite sheet so
the way that we're going to do this is
we know the size of sprites don't we so
we just need a simple um for loop here
the thing is we might be creating new
sprites every time that might not be the
most efficient way to do things unless
we do it statically I think we're going
to do it that way
so let's make an array of sprites called
sprites essentially again and what this
will do will change public's sprite to
be an array instead of a just one sprite
and what we're gonna do here especially
in the sub share we might add this into
the other sheets later but this is the
subject creation what we want to do is
as we take each sprite out of this array
we want to pop it into this sprite array
okay in fact that kind of even makes
this a bit redundant here because
instead of setting all the pixels we're
going to do this but that's alright
we'll set it that way as well
so for int this is actually really quite
this quite simple to set up
so for
we'll just go with Weiser again why 0 is
equal to 0 y 0 is less than how many
sprites we won't deal with height so I
believe height is height is referring to
the parameter which in our case is the
number of sprites rather than the number
of sprite vertically rather than the
number of pixels vertically and we'll do
the same thing for X and of course
change this to with so that's just
iterate throw a surprise and we'll all
we want to do here is we want to create
a new sprite so let's make a sprite
sprite equal new sprite and let's see
what kind constructors we have here so
we have an Inside memory a little bear
let's see if we've actually got a way do
this through pixel array not exactly
okay I'm just gonna think about how
we're gonna do this I think that we're
gonna have to make on the deals with a
pixel area but let's deal with these
pixels first okay what we want to do is
out of these pixels that are now in the
spreadsheet we want to kind of take a
section of those pixels and add them
into the sprite so again we're kind of
cropping pixels again it's gonna be
quite a lengthy episode isn't it anyway
okay so in that case I think we probably
won't be able to do it this way we'll
have to actually do it through pixels
here so because of that I'm sure this is
going to be quite a difficult method to
implement into um into a universal thing
let's say no that's fine well um we'll
have to do it this way okay cool so this
will iterate through our entire sprite
sheet again this is what will probably
move this in here in a minute here but I
just want to make sure that you guys get
it get how it works um just like that
okay so the idea here is to the thing is
we're going um horizontally here first
so that actually works really well for
this all we need to say here is we need
construct first of all a spider right
here sir no I think a smarter way of
doing this to me is quite a lot of ways
you can do this but I think a smarter
way of doing this would probably be um
whatever it was haven't used you uh I'll
just make it why a 4 y equals 0 and then
Y is actually going to be less than
number of surprise we have vertically
yeah this will probably be a bit faster
as well although speed really doesn't
matter too much here since this is in a
armed continuous operation so I'll
explain what I'm doing in just a sec
make sure that you have course use the
correct variable names here we're
actually going to move this for loop
into that for loop and the way this is
gonna work is we've we're a quadruple
for loop I don't think we've ever done
that before
basically this these two these are going
to iterate through our on actual
physical sprites so in other words
height in this case is of course equal
to three since we have straights price
here right one two three and width in
this case can equal to one since we're
extracting just the um you can see over
here that we're extracting just one here
so of course with is one height is three
so for each of these sprites it's
actually going to individually select
them and put them into a pixel array and
the way we can do that is just under
here we're gonna actually make a pixel
array alcohol pixels equals new int and
this will be the width and height of an
individual it's bright so in other words
sprite size I believe we didn't make
them square for now so sprite size times
sprite sighs I think I might make a
class in the future this just to do with
sizes glue putting in width and in
height everywhere and coordinates as
well that could be um much cleaner if we
actually make a class that just has
these four integers or these three
integers okay so now I've met a new
pixel array what we need to do now is
select a winning it first will populate
that pixel array so pixels at make sure
that we use these new ones here so x0
plus y0 times our sprite size
is actually going to equal the sheets
pixels which are oh great
no let's not call his pixels let's call
these sprite pixels it's right sprite
pixels okay sprite we already got
another one called two pixels it's
actually going to equal pixels and these
are the actual pixels of the sprite
sheet not of this new array the with the
way of making like a sub array is
actually going to equal pixels now we
need to make sure that we offset it by
which sprite we're up to in the sheet so
in that case and that's relatively
simple to do what we'll need to do is
make sure that what we need to do is
just make sure that we also include
these so it's pretty simple since these
are going to be these are in table
precision and these are in pixel
precision so let's pop in X your plus
our X a which is in sprite precision
because since bright a sprite precision
precision make sure that we actually
multiply by sprite size to get it back
into pixel precision since in a pixel
array we're dealing with pixels same
thing for y plus y times sprite sides
and make sure that we are also close
multiplied by the sheets width which is
just width okay
that way I think we put shape with here
that's probably not okay oh this is the
sheet okay so make sure that um okay so
we're not getting okay yeah we don't
need to go [ __ ] up with because that's
this shades with and one we where we've
already extracted it out of the shades
emitted so we just want to deal with
this one again these are just subtle
errors that can really ruin your day so
make sure that you um logically think
about this as well okay cool so now that
we've done that we've got a pixel array
and that pixel array contains just one
sprite out of the sprite array okay now
and this will actually be a universal
method that will work because what we're
doing with this essentially here and
with this we're we're kind of using a
modulus by not using a modular so in
other words we're saying that when you
get to the end of the sprite just take
one area out of the out of the sprite
sheet just one square area which is
defined by sprite size okay
so now we need to make a new sprite out
of this pixel array so we'll just pop in
sprite pixels and we'll give it a width
in height we have to give it a width in
height so in fact what we don't cyst
which is equal to high it will just make
it a sprite size for now but again I
don't want to keep this universal so
I'll okay make both of them so now let's
create a constructor for that Nam and
this is going to be like the easiest
constructor ever so size is going to
equal well just copy and paste our on
this size argument here
so if width equals all right and this
will be pixels so that's what size is
gonna equal so otherwise though we make
sure we have to make sure that we
actually do set this up with equals
height and sorry
so that was the probably the stupidest
statement I swear let me just fix that
in a minute there's still hard equals
height and of course it's top width
equals width and thing is one mistake
like that weren't actually affected
because um this is square in this case
so this is how I'm a lot of a lot of
people make a little errors so anyway
once we've done that make sure that we
do set this top pixels equal through the
pixels that we specify okay cool
and that should that should actually
work properly so this is a pretty easy
um method constructor what we don't know
would have to load anything because it's
that simple so yeah okay cool so back to
UM no hang on back to sprites a for a
minute where are we
I'll get sprite okay cool oh okay
so now that we've made this sprite we
need to actually add it into our pixels
so let's see
we need to add it at the end here so we
need to first of all keep track of an of
which frame we're adding so we'll make
in frame equal zero every time we
iterate the frame we'll add 1 to frame
and then at the very end of this so at
the very end of these two we need to go
ahead and sprites frame equals sprite
okay and in fact what's wrong with this
oh right okay so I think oh we could
just move this down here really can't we
okay cool
and we're adding to that in fact I'm
probably gonna delete this frame split
plus here and just put frame plus plus
into here which basically means that um
as soon as it adds a sprite into the
into the sprites array it's gonna just
iterate frames gonna add one to the
frame so the next time it will be um
it'll be different okay so that is the
map that is quite a complicated method
I'm not gonna lie right now that
actually I had to stop and think there
for a minute because I'm doing the top
of my head so it's not guaranteed to be
correct but I think this is right it
looks right to me right now so now what
we should do over here is we just return
the sprites so first things first let's
go into that animated sprite and sets
sprites equal to okay
let's also make sure that okay sheet is
stored in um in super right yeah where's
our sheet yes right shade shade is
stored in them you know the super class
so sprite equals sheet dot get what's a
cold is a private
I think it's private okay it's private
let's change that to protected
so ASP radical she get sprite at index
array frame now this should essentially
be correct in fact I'm thinking we might
not need length here at all ah no I
think I think we'll keep it in okay I'll
quickly explain what I mean by that the
reason is of course
we know the length of this sprite array
because sprite dot sprite if we go to
this there's there is a dot length field
and we can find out the length but the
thing is even if your sprite array might
even even if your sprite sheet might
have 20 sprites in it you might only
want to use 10 for the animation so you
might want to crop it so that's that's
the deal also one thing we want to find
out is just to handle this error or at
least tell us that there's an hour we'll
go ahead and say that if length is
actually greater than sheet dot get
sprites it should be called get sprites
dot length will change every minute dot
length then I will go ahead and go
system dot error dot print line error
this is like the best error with a
printed isn't it length of animation is
too long or something like that so let's
change with change this gets right
method to be in a spreadsheet to be get
sprites rather than get sprite and I
think we're done
okay so that's up that's pretty simple
okay in this class of course in sprite
shape we have to do some fancy some
fancy things and this right here needs
to be probably um so if so time plus
plus when you make sure we make one for
time private in time equals zero so time
plus loss and if time mod hour you can
use end as well but time mod our rate is
equal to zero
yeah equal to zero then we'll do this
stuff okay
and that's that's actually going to loop
through our animation now I'm not going
to test this right now because there's a
few that's quite a bit more code that we
want to write but I will make sure that
it is iterating through these and the
way that we can do that is let's go into
player for example and in player I'm
actually going to make a new animator
sprite so private animated sprite
test equals new animated sprite and I'll
take a sprite sheet dot play it down
now the width in I think this is the
with another man and what's it this is
the width in I think it's that yeah I
know 32 and the length of course of the
animation is three and let's go ahead
over here we need to make sure that we
update so test update and all I want to
do here you know Matt is bright it just
print out the frame so system dot out
dot print line will print the sprite
plus frame okay okay and that will give
us a good an indication of whether stuff
is working or not so let's run that okay
so we get it we get an array index out
of bounds seven probably yep okay so
we've got an array index out of bounds
exception let's find out what sorry this
Epps has gonna be very long I'm really
sorry I probably should have dived into
this but um let's see what's out of
bounds first of all is it pixels I'm
gonna tell is that this hang on
I wish it would tell me these days I
think it's some okay so what's happening
from the player down and it's happening
right over here okay so this is
fantastic now I need to find out which
array is out of balance here so that's
equal to 32 times oh hang on Matt if Y
zero is 32 oh that's fine yeah that's
fine X zero is 1 that's 0 times that
it's okay this give it a zero this gives
us 32 plus zero times 32 this gives us
32 times width which is 32 that should
be this should be fine I'd say so this
is probably where the error is
it's a sprite sprite size is equal to 32
why is 0 is equal to 32 and that's fine
as well so why is that giving us and
right next out of bounds exception that
should be fine let's um
it's diagnosis quickly so let's set
let's just print out the I'll just
whoops
I'll pray this out as an arrow so we can
identify quickly so let's print out
sprite pixels dot length and let's print
out pixels dot link whoops okay so let's
check that out
all right so the length of this is 1024
let's bust out our calculator so you
just go standard yeah so 32 times 32 is
1024 which is correct that should be the
size of that and our sprite sheet should
be 32 times 32 times 3 times 32 which is
3072 so that's fine so clearly something
is wrong with our actual full loop here
the UM arrays are properly initialized
so with this one height is 3 height here
is 96 oh so here's the problem
height here is 96 with this fine so this
height is the height of um not each
individual sprite which it should be but
rather the actual height here so this
should be set to sprite size and this
should be set to sprite size ok so
pretty subtle but make sure that you set
that up correctly and let's play it
again so we get okay so now we have a
null pointer exception for sprites of
sprites equals null okay we never met a
sprite or I did away it's up here so now
let's make sure that since we do know
the length here let's set sprites equal
to new sprite and it will be let's see
here so I think we do know right width
times height because this width is yeah
that'll give us 3 I guess correct let's
try that again
okay we crashed again but I think we did
frame 1 here frame
to hear that worked and as soon as we
got to frame three we crashed oh I see
okay and emotionally okay that's makes
sense okay because we start at zero so
make sure this is equal to let's run
that again no that's still crashed so
frame ok frame is equal to three frame
three one two three I'm thinking that
the thing is when you specify frames
though frame numbers are captors you
want frame numbers to be one two and
three you don't want them to be 0 1 to D
or it does frame 0 work for you guys I
don't know because in video whatever you
the first frame is frame 1 mile frame 0
so I'm just thinking if you gather one
to be like that I don't know
he said length what's the length that we
said length we set is 3 right okay so we
set the length to be 3 and frame here is
equal to 3
that's your set frame back to 0 actually
huh it's just um and again that should
be setting frame back to 0 because it
says if frame is greater than or equal
to length length is 3 frame is equal to
length in this point unless it does that
after ok we could add this here I guess
ok so now you can see here if I stop
this we all opening through frame 0
frame 1 and frame 2 and that is giving
us different sprites as you can see for
each frame if you are enlarged less
quickly in fact let me quickly go to
window preferences general not maybe not
general and oh yeah this in general
general editors text editors it's an
appearance calls and fonts so it's been
a while so for the um console where is
it that's the editor font
where's the UM was it comes off on it's
supposed to be here isn't it
movies in debug yeah console font edit
I'm just gonna increase that to be a
sixteen okay so yeah okay so we see that
for frame zero as you can see the actual
identifier for the unique instance of
sprite is 69 81 or whatever 69 we'll
call it for one it's 59 and for two it's
121 and as you can see it goes back to
69 so we can see just by reading this
text is that it is looping through a
bunch of different sprites now because
you guys probably want to see what that
looks like on screen and because it's
actually gonna be a one line command to
get it to print on the screen are -
sorry - um updated sprite here all I'm
gonna do is we are getting the sprite
here so all I'll do is I'll actually set
our sprite right now how do we set that
so we set it to play it forward and
depending on which way he walks
we actually set it differently so just
before we render let's set sprite equal
to test dot get sprite and that should
um if we go to this this should that
should depth that returns ice price
let's take a look about okay we crashed
again
what's null here sprite a nice personal
okay hang on now I think we said that
correctly in animated sprites or sprite
equals okay so make sure we set it a
false pride so sprite at the mark sprite
should equal sheet don't get sprites 0
to begin with otherwise we get a null
error here okay so you can see right now
that we've got our character here and
he's dancing um okay
and you can see this Dan he's a bit
off-center as well but doesn't matter
he's dancing here is pretty happy you
guys can see how good my drawing ability
is and we're actually animating I'll
play out by using essentially in the
player class one two lines of code okay
and one to actually make him okay
instead of all this
animation stuff so that simplifies
things a lot and I hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of game programming man
this is a long episode this almost felt
like a 3d game programming episode
because this is usually what they're
like but I hope you guys took something
away from this if you did please hit the
like button if we do hit 300 likes I
will make two episodes in one day
otherwise if we hit two unrelaxed
I will release an episode tomorrow so
please hit like hit the like button if
you guys enjoy this video and I'll see
you guys next time good bye
you